fait non non je vais maintenant demander
à monsieur le procureur des proches de
la république de bien vouloir procéder
au réquisitoire de la société envers
l'individu claude chabrol d'abord dire
que j'écris ce réquisitoire en toute
tranquillité dans ma vie la bretonne et
d'un pierre oui avec kerman quand je
vous prie monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les jurés public chéri une
fois n'est pas coutume et se demanderait
aujourd'hui à la cour à tout tout titre
tout à fait exceptionnel de commencer
mon réquisitoire par une réflexion
d'ordre personnel touchant à ma vie
familiale
monsieur le président puis je me permets
de cet aparté qui sera bref on parlait
pas de josiane non pas du tout en fait
faut que tu l'appelles présidentielle je
parle que les oui eh bien monsieur le
juré aujourd'hui 22 septembre 1981 c'est
la saint maurice et je vous demanderai à
tous une pensée émue pour mon cousin
maurice qui mourut tragiquement lors de
la libération de paris
comme tant de jeunes et braves petits
français lâchement abattu par un effet
fille alors qu'on tentait d'attraper le
paris berlin la gare de l'est
cette digression agression terminée
revenons-en à ce triste sire à la trogne
chafouine qui somnole à présent dans son
box
indifférent à mésaventures de mon cousin
maurice je vais vous surprendre monsieur
le président mais vraiment et vous plus
encore m rigolote année
je vais vous surprendre m mais malgré
l'attachement que je porte ma fonction
répressive
malgré l'amour que j'ai de la schlague
malgré la tendresse que m'inspire la
guillotine
je ne puis hélas qu être indulgent pour
ce pauvre monsieur chabrol ici présents
car c'est un brave homme
alors elle essaiera de le défendre je
suis désolé c'est se présente comme ça
ben écoute et non je proteste le
président est m soyons que les
classements boulot là m soyons clair que
reproche-t-on à ce pauvre monsieur
chabrol
on l'accuse d'avoir trahi sa jeunesse et
bien moi mesdames et messieurs les jurés
je dis bravo
je dis bravo parce que dans un pays où
la jeunesse constitue le seul vrai
danger potentiel pour l'ordre public
comment peut-on reprocher à quelqu'un de
trahir la sienne je vous le demande
trahir sa jeunesse c'est trahir la
subversion c'est dire non des ordres
c'est repoussé le spectre rouge c'est
presque aussi beau que de voter le pen
alors on ne demande pas à moi à moi qui
suis le pilier de ce tribunal
d'exception elle qu'on ne me demande pas
d'exiger la tête d'un homme aux portes
de la sénilité l'agilité la sénilité
trouillarde pataude et rabougrie qui est
le plus sûr garant des grandes
démocraties molle comme la nôtre comme
le dirait volontiers le maître
d'abeilles ou six films ce qui est
décidément le philosophe titre et de ce
tribunal
quelqu'un qui trahit sa jeunesse ne peut
pas être tout à fait mauvais claude
chabrol aurait pu être pharmacien comme
pas par nous l'a dit tout à l'heure
il a d'ailleurs commencé de brillantes
études de pharmacie mais il les a
bientôt abandonner pour aller vendre des
fruits de mer à l'entracte du gaumont
palace
et oui mesdames et messieurs les jurés
les cahiers du cinéma s'étaient mis
d'accord maintenant
maintenant j'en suis sûr maintenant
qu'il a terminé sa puberté
cinématographique
il regrette les joies de la piscine et
la fière blouse blanche de l'apothicaire
d'où une certaine nostalgie pharmaco
fils qu'on ressent de plus en plus
souvent dans les films de claude chabrol
où les travellings laxatifs succèdent
sans fin au dialogue barbituriques au
train où vont les choses les films de
claude chabrol ne pas utiliser de façon
prolongée sans avis médical seront
bientôt remboursés par la sécurité
sociale et madame patenôtre qui avait
failli mourir de stupeur face à
l'immoralité des cousins va bientôt
militer pour la candidature de claude
chabrol sous lacombe la coupole
gérontophile du quai conti
monsieur chabrol vous avez dit un jour
je vous cite si j'étais procureur je
ferais condamner les gens pour défaut de
continuer de continuité dans la pensée
aussi bien suis-je obligé malgré moi
d'être sévère avec vous et le demande je
demande que vous ayez la tête tranchée
mais je mettrais comme une certaine
indulgence je demande que vous ayez la
tête tranchée sans vos lunettes afin que
vous ne voyez pas le fond du pays
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
etonnant non